bom eu tinha 12 anos quando comecei a
praticar karatê
naquela época eu brigava muito
de quatro a cinco vezes por semana
brigava na escola nas ruas em qualquer
lugar a vencer nenhum motivo pessoal
olhava pra mim tá no chamado abrir o dia
bate muito e um adolescente que era
subir de a pessoa muito perigosa e
violenta o chefe de brigada do dos
bairros da cidade grande
quando ficou sabendo disse que ia me
matar
imagine lógico que fiquei apavorado
então todos os dias quando ia sair de
casa
eu tentava me prevenir de alguma forma
côncava pode ferro chinês gols como pó
de ferro que eu conseguir uma
funcionária que ficava do lado da minha
casa
essa rotina durou um tempo
um dia me encontrei com aquele homem
perigoso violento que tinha muito medo
quando ele me viu ele disse você é uma
criança
não vou te matar mas eu vou te dar uma
bela só nos bolsos
joguei até as imagens de ferro nos olhos
dele e ele ficou maluca foi terrível bem
aproveitei e bati muito
bati muito e corri para casa
durante a minha ida tem caso ficar
pensando nas conseqüências na possível
revanche
como vou fazer chegando em casa pensei
acho que vou ter que me aperfeiçoar para
brigar vou procurar uma arte marcial no
dia seguinte cento está o rio grande que
era muito famosa escolher a modalidade
karatê me matriculei me dedicar aos
treinamentos intensamente que era muito
muito pesada muito rigoroso
aos poucos fui notando significa
significativas mudança e eu fiquei mais
tolerante olhar pra mim que eu não ia eu
tenho mais confiança em mim então eu não
queria aquele aquela minha preocupação
em aperfeiçoar para abrigar foi sendo
jogada por terra e aquela minha
preocupação com a possível revanche não
estava mais na minha lista de
preocupações
o que eu queria mesmo é ser orgulho para
minha família e meu sensei o caráter
mudou completamente o rumo da minha vida
e é sobre essa história de transformação
que eu quero falar hoje com vocês
aos 18 anos me mudei para cuiabá com a
ajuda da mesma treta para estudar
engenharia aqui na ufmt
que eu estar jeito construir várias
obras
a primeira foi a rio ea última foi a
biblioteca e obra me no final do meu
curso
eu tinha muita sorte tinha opções de
vários empregos
exatamente 4 mas eu escolhi trabalhar na
infraero
trabalhei 11 anos
inicialmente como engenheiro depois
assumiu imediatamente os cargos de
gerente de operações manutenção
segurança e estilo superintendente do
aeroporto de cuiabá por diversas vezes
lá eu aprendi muito me especializei
receber um excelente salário
gostava muito do que fazer das pessoas
eu era muito querido por todos
um ano antes de me formar
eu me casei com a agenda está aqui que
eu namorava desde que eu era aquele
menino brigam e ela me tolerável
tivemos três filhos rodrigo pelo gênio
se formou em administração de empresas
mas hoje ele vive em dubai professor de
caratê em dubai
e é esse o técnico nos pelo caráter dos
emirados árabes
fernando e não está mais entre nós e
renato o meu caçula em educação física e
fisioterapia trabalha com a mãe na
técnica mas também a karateca faixa
preta 2º dan então aquele menino de 12
anos que brigava muito e se transformou
cresceu se formou construiu família
conseguiu excelente emprego com
possibilidade de uma boa aposentadoria
integral projetou e construiu sua
própria casa com o carro novo continua
participando de competições de cursos
parece uma vida perfeita na verdade era
que mais alguém precisa mas na verdade
eu sentia que não estava lá estava não
tinha chegado ao meu propósito de vida
dentro de mim havia um sentimento de que
eu deveria me dedicar mais ao karatê
para compartilhar tudo aquilo que me
proporcionou profissional aquele menino
e transformou a vida a minha vida
inicialmente o objetivo era elevar o
caráter de mato grosso livre de
excelência me dediquei na formação dos
meus atletas
logo em seguida foi reconhecido como os
melhores do brasil mas para dar
continuidade àquele desenvolvimento e
chegar à excelência a nível mundial
eu precisava me dedicar quase que
exclusivamente o carácter e aí vem o
conflito como fazer vou largar deixar a
minha posição de gênero
agora como mas como fazer federal com a
possibilidade um bom salário e me
dedicar ao esporte amador
conversei com muitas pessoas a maioria
disse ó continua emprego você vai ser
considerado racional louco
ao contrário minha família é o grande
mestre me apoiava incondicionalmente
eu sofri
sofri muito para tomar a decisão foi rio
foi uma luta terrível era terrível
mas quando eu voltei aquele menino a
memória e atendimento de 12 anos que
brigava muito que tinha muita sorte nas
brigas mas teve uma chance encontrou no
encerramento declara ter uma nova
da vida aí sim decidir ser professor de
caratê enquanto gênero
dei o melhor de mim agora vou fazer o
mesmo com o caratê mas o que é o karatê
que filosofia está inserida nessa arte
milenar
o que é tão transformador que me fez me
dedicar completamente à temática de
defesa pessoal desenvolvida no japão
no caso de não se usar mas nos
treinamentos
aprendemos ao nosso corpo tá efetuar a
executar as defesas mas muito além de
tudo isso ele ensina princípios
filosóficos que atuam diretamente na
formação do caráter e da personalidade
do ser humano
e era isso que eu tinha que passar a
transmitir para os meus alunos mais
importante que ganhar medalhas ou
títulos em competições cba transformação
pessoal de cada um para alcançar os
objetivos
busquei capacitação perfeiçoamento
técnico nós testamos com as fãs de
seminários eventos e campeonatos junto
nós conquistamos muitos títulos
a nossa academia passou a ser
considerada uma das melhores do ano de
2000 uma escola nós recebemos um contato
de uma escola pública estava sob
intervenção e tinha graves problemas
particulares
os alunos daquela unidade escolar
apresentavam gravíssimos problemas e
indisciplina e violência do agente de
aprendizagem e permaneça em sala de aula
repetência e formação de gangues
os professores
se o medo daqueles que deveriam ensinar
como tudo acontece na hora certa
tivemos ali a grande oportunidade para
usar o karatê
essa ferramenta transformadora que
tínhamos nas mãos e assim levar esse
trabalho a um outro patamar atingir mais
pessoas vão ver mais informações
a nossa proposta aparentemente simples
usar o catar tem como ferramenta
educacional para todos os alunos da
escola de 1ª a 4ª série mas não foi tão
simples assim
no início houve resistência da própria
equipe gestora da escola que achava
contraditório ensinar uma arte marcial
há alunos que apresentavam graves nos
problemas de agressividade e violência
em princípio poderia ser até uma
conclusão lógica pois não conhecia o
poder depois de negociações conversa e
exemplos nos 100 m são montamos a equipe
fomos em loco
avaliamos e planejarmos ações
a primeira visita foi impactante
vimos que o nível de indisciplina e
dificuldade de socialização das crianças
era visitante ficou claro muito claro os
motivos que levaram os professores a
terem medo daqueles que deveriam educar
não era com certeza o grande desafio mas
como sempre digo problemas foram feitos
para nos fazer mais inteligentes
nós não fugimos do compromisso dos
objetivos
tivemos que aprender a nos adaptar à
nova realidade social
os alunos para que as metas fossem
alcançadas e com as mentes abertas muita
determinação
começamos aulas para todos os alunos
duas vezes por semana logo em seguida
vieram os resultados com quatro meses de
implantação
ficamos muito animados notou se uma
melhora considerável em vários aspectos
complementares
depois de um ano e meio foi feita uma
pesquisa através da comunidade escolar
constatando expressiva mudança compor
nada comportamental escolar e familiar
os resultados impressionaram os atores
melhoria de 80% dos objetivos propostos
ou seja o que tinha acontecido na tela
naquela escola era uma transformação
ficou claro que os valores do catete
tinham tirado dos alunos à violência
agressividade à vontade de brigar disso
o caminho do respeito da disciplina a
dedicação ea valorização da educação
e foi esse desafio
o primeiro passo para o pdt
o projeto foi crescendo desde as escolas
2000 foram beneficiadas mais de 15 mil
crianças adolescentes e adultos sem
nenhum custo algum
pelas aulas pelo investimento em outras
e outras vantagens
atualmente o projeto é desenvolvido na
sede da sucan nas escolas e várias
associações parceiras
nós somos eternamente gratos a todos
todos os parceiros que contribuíram para
o sucesso e gostaria de destacar a
unesco e o programa criança esperança
que nos deve exibir usados nacional e
internacional com essas parcerias
podemos estamos transformando a vida de
milhares de crianças adolescentes e
adultos na grande cuiabá
eles já estão exportando os valores o
quarteira para o mundo muitos deles já
foram campeões nacionais americanos e
mundiais tiveram a oportunidade de
viajar e conhecer o assim como eu fiz
eles também tiveram a oportunidade de
subir ao pódio pelos campeonatos e
também vários daqueles alunos a 18 anos
que iniciaram sua transformação daquela
escola conturbada pois são profissionais
sérios respeitáveis e cidadão de bem
eu fiz uma escolha seguir meu propósito
com muita vontade determinação e venci
porque aquele engenheiro e optou em ser
professor de caratê acreditou felizmente
que vale a pena foca que eu vejo
fácil não foi
não foi nada fácil foi difícil
foi tudo muitas dúvidas muito medo
muitas quedas muitas dificuldades
financeiras
de repente você se vê sem nada onde
tirar para se manter e ainda tem que
correr sair com o pires na mão pedindo
patrocínio é que você vai levar seus
alunos a eventos e campeonatos comprar a
vestimenta remédios alimentação vale
transporte
porém nunca voltei meu pensamento ao
passado com arrependimento
absolutamente por que iniciará as aulas
ao ensinar aquelas crianças
as técnicas e os princípios e ver no
rosto deles
a vontade é a satisfação ea vontade de
crescer
eu esqueço tudo só pensa em continuar a
satisfação e reconhecimento e gratidão
por tudo isso eu afirma que a
transformação através do karatê é
possível sim
aquele menino lá atrás de 12 anos que
não tinha sonhos apenas medos ea vontade
de brigar para sobreviver
teve uma chance quando foi buscar ajuda
para melhorar sua performance para
abrigar teve mãos estendidas e você o
que a vida tem outras possibilidades
quando se tem vontade de mudar
eu passei por transformação e hoje vejo
muitas transformações acontecendo diante
dos meus olhos
às vezes fico pensando
fico imaginando onde estaria a ter menos
de 12 anos
bigham caso não tivesse sido uma chance
será que ainda estaria vivo
obrigado
[Aplausos]